[Music]
here are the 12 ranks and cars of
xenomorphs in a hive keeping in mind
that this hype would be a very mature
one having all necessary types of aliens
we would be discussing the
multi-planetary hive world system with
the center of it all at xenomorph prime
itself so let's start from the lowest
scars
number one at the bottom we have the
workers the worker is a rare xenomorph
that changes from a drone when needed by
the hive specifically the worker shrinks
into a smaller organism after changing
from a drone they are one of the only
adult xenomorph cars that may be
characterized as non-violent these
little creatures are much smaller than
any other adult species about 1.2 meters
or 4 feet and they seldom ever leave the
hive won't even go after dangers inside
the hive and will run away if confronted
second we have the drones these are the
first of the xenomorphs to be seen and
are also the most common the precise
physical traits of drones can vary just
like with any cinema of cars most
visibly many variations in the
creature's skull characters have been
observed anyway drones are swift and
moderately tough and can engage in
vicious close quarters combat as well as
planned stealth strikes their main work
is to tend to the hive defend it and
also gather resources for producing more
of them
then next we have the specialized drones
one of them is the lurker and it is
younger than a warrior but older than a
drone the alien from the first movie was
the only known individual lurker their
transparent shells on the top of their
heads make it possible to see their
skulls this makes it possible to view
their eye holes as well as nostril holes
as well as black patterns on their
skulls they have more human-like traits
such as posture hands and feet and their
skin is more grey than black there is
also another variation the runner which
is another specialized drone that came
out of a bull or a dog depending on
which storyline you like
then number four we have the warriors
these are one of the main xenomorph cast
types and it is a fierce combatant quick
and moderately tough the warrior is
harmful even after death breaking into
pieces and dousing adjacent adversaries
in acid blood the warrior has a height
of around 8 feet making it taller than a
drone and also a predator and its tail
is roughly 14 to 16 feet long it has
long segmented tails which is all black
and has a second set of jaws inside its
mouth that it may use to kill or maim
animals
then we have the specialized warriors
one of them the crusher has a huge head
crest which is reported to be entirely
bulletproof it also has the propensity
to charge its prey and deal massive
blunt force which are its most
distinctive characteristic it serves as
a kind of a heavy unit for the hive
there is also another one the prowler
which is another warrior variation it is
primarily black in color but its
mesoskeleton possesses reddish accents
that are often found solely on members
of the runner cars it has a noticeable
headquarters and its body seems to be
moderately armoured
then going up one car's level we have
the praetorian which is also referred to
as the royal guard and it is one of the
last stages of its life cycle the
xenomorph life cycle and possibly the
most prevalent and well-known cars to
emerge from a vast extended universe
when a high population exceeds 300
individuals praetorians are born and
become the royal god and army commanders
of the queen or the empress
praetorians rarely venture outside of
the confines of the hive in contrast to
other cinema of kinds like the drones
and the warriors
then as the others we also have the
specialized praetorians
carriers are one such of them they are
an evolutionary stage of a praetorian
the carrier resembles an outsized drone
with its ashen mesoskeleton and smooth
carapace it is noticeably shorter than a
queen but also a few feet taller than a
warrior and a praetorian it has
specialized evolved dorsal tubes which
it can launch
face huggers and also designed to hold
the facehuggers in them
then we have the ravager which is
another praetorian variant that is
highly dangerous and unlike other
xenomorphs it is a hyper aggressive
killing machine with absolutely no
interest in capturing victims alive to
act as hoes for more cinemas
now we come to the level of the leaders
of the xenomorph hives and firstly we
start with the queens at number eight
and starting with the queens which is
one of the larger forms of the species
of the cinema of xx121
that serves both as the mother and
leader of a hive queens are one of the
largest strongest and most intelligent
xenomorph cars and their appearance
differs from other smaller variants with
a pair of extra arms growing from their
chest and a large headgrass extending
rear wards from their skull she is the
sole egg layer of a hive and is
responsible for leading just one
singular hive
then we have the rogue queens and the
predalien queen
just as the drones and praetorians have
their variants so thus the queen the
most notable variant are the red queens
which are leaders of the red xenomorphs
that rebelled against a primary hive and
established a separate hive system
called the red army
then we also have the predalien
surprisingly which is also a queen
xenomorph which is still a juvenile
during the events of avp requiem when it
grows and matures it will also gain the
ability to lay eggs in huge numbers and
form a hive that it will rule
then at number 10 we have the kings well
aside from the queen variants there is
another hive leave the cars which is
very rare in that they are males the
king is a large and rare form that is
only known to exist in the largest of
the cinema of hives they are very
similar to the queen but are much more
built for combat not for egg laying most
evidence would seem to point to the king
being a commander cass way above the
praetorians that would act as a hulking
field commander for the lesser cause he
would also hold a position of importance
close to or as a counterpart to the
queen
then we go one more cars upwards and we
have the empress this cause of zinemos
is a step above the queen king and rogue
royals she is the evolved form of a
queen alien and one of the three female
types of xenomorph monarchs herrera type
empresses are superior to queen aliens
often ruling over several queens in
their respective hives they themselves
only bow down to the hive mother the
supreme ruler of all xenomorph species
they are also a bit larger than queens
being 15 to 20 feet tall
empresses notably may cohabit a single
territory with several queens making the
others subordinate to her will
and lastly we have the queen mother this
is the rarest and the most powerful of
all the xenomorphs also known as the
hive mother
the supermother or the uber queen
not the queen that drives ubers in high
heels but you know it rules over a vast
hive world most notably cinema of prime
and also communicates with and or
controls of world hives as well queen
mothers have been said to come into
being by growing from an existing queen
or empress presumably with the emperor's
variance as an intermediary form
this evolution is driven by the size of
the hive which drives the size of the
queen as well which in turn influences
the virility of the hive in a vicious
cycle
the ultimate cause the queen mother is
50 feet tall or 15 meters in height
which means she is also the biggest
xenomorph
there are also other variants of xenos
that haven't been included like the
newborn and the white king hybrids but
i'll leave that to you guys to arrange
in that hive so i hope you have enjoyed
watching this video do hit that like
button for support and subscribe as well
but most of all smash that bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel
till the next one take care fam